eric zemmour esquisse un sourire le
chroniqueur se veut confiant mais se
refuse à tout commentaire
[Musique]
à la barre le journaliste et combatif il
maintient les propos qu'il a tenus en
mars dernier lors d'un débat télévisé
poursuivi pour diffamation
il n'ya pourtant rien de condamnable aux
yeux d'eric zemmour la parole d'eric
zemmour n'a jamais été une parole
raciste
c'est une parole libre à société a
évolué et a changé le seuil de tolérance
n'est plus le même et bien s'agissant
des propos d'eric zemmour c'est
exactement la même chose nous ne voulons
pas évidemment jeté l'anathème sur eric
zemmour c'est pas ça le sujet la
question est de savoir quelle est celle
de la responsabilité d'un meneur de
débats ou d'un chroniqueur qui est un
leader d'opinion n'at-il pas en même
temps que des droits des devoirs est ce
que vous sentez aujourd'hui en conflit
contre la justice non je ne suis pas en
conflit contre la justice vous savez
vous avez dit j'étais condamné trois
fois non j'ai deux fois définitivement
oui mais une fois attendait une
procédure en appel voilà et là la
première fois j'ai été condamné en 2011
je n'ai pas voulu faire appel mais
seraient d'accord la deuxième fois j'ai
été condamné vous avez raison
définitivement mais en france la
procédure continue devant la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme mais
peu importe
la première fois donc la seule fois la
vraie condamnation la véritable
condamnation pardon c'est pour avoir dit
que la plupart des délinquants étaient
noirs et arabes
dans un débat franchement toute la
france pansard aujourd'hui tout le monde
le sait je n'ai été condamné que pour d
avoir dit la vérité donc je ne suis pas
en conflit avec la justice je ne suis en
tout cas pas en conflit avec la vérité
et je ne suis pas en conflit avec ce que
pense le peuple français maintenant il y
a effectivement deux choses une loi qui
a été une loi dite plevent de 72 qui a
été dévoyé par des juges de gauche pour
en faire une arme politique pour
ostracisés et pour
punir une dp propos contre l'immigration
pour qui dénonce la délinquance
étrangère où la délinquance est immigré
d'où ma question
votre guerre contre la justice donc
c'est pas une guerre c'est simplement le
chaussant sol et ise de gauche oui alors
si vous voulez si vous voulez contre eux
je suis dans un conflit politique
puisque eux mêmes font de la politique
et instrumentalise la justice pour me
combattre politiquement donc moi je les
combats politiques si vous voulez
[Musique]